members of Congress today everyone's
talking about Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu's speech to a joint
session of Congress this Capitol dome
helped build our Iron Dome is it a music
speech was coordinated behind the
president's back with congressional
Republicans illustrating his opposition
to President Obama's proposed deal with
Iran to limit its nuclear program in
exchange for lifting international
sanctions Netanyahu thinks this would be
a disaster here's the basic meat of this
argument I don't believe that Iran's
radical regime will change for the
better after this deal this regime has
been in power for 36 years and its
voracious appetite for aggression grows
with each passing year this deal would
whet appetite would only whet Iran's
appetite for more would Iran be less
aggressive when sanctions are removed
and its economy is stronger if Iran is
gobbling up four countries right now
while it's under sanctions how many more
countries will Iran devour when
sanctions are lifted would Iran fund
less terrorism when it has mountains of
cash with which to fund more terrorism
why should Iran's radical regime change
for the better when it can enjoy the
best of both worlds
aggression abroad prosperity at home the
case that Netanyahu is making there is
that Iran is a rogue radical regime bent
on overthrowing the political order in
the Middle East and using its nuclear
capability as a tool to enable the kind
of aggression that it's doing right now
through fun and militant groups let's
bowl up huh Netanyahu thinks a
nuclear-armed Iran like this would be an
unacceptable danger and would probably
cheat on any deal to get a weapon Obama
by contrast thinks Iran does do bad
things he also thinks that Iran can
respond rashly to incentives so it knows
that sanctions are hurting its economy
but is willing to suspend its nuclear
program in exchange for a healthier
better
Oh
you
you